welcome to this video playing step by
step from from from from Bulgaria right
bulgaria yep I've got a 50-percent score
against him an entire own fault I
recently saw some video by in German
Grand Master yang gustafson they
recommended the queen bee three move
this Knight takes c3 is just just not
good simply need to go to be 6 and now
he's got this is really awkward
information on the Kings side wow I'm
not sure that I would have checked
castle into that so so willingly but ok
maybe there's no not not a big big
choice of course I'm thinking about age
form I am that this it's just good to
play it for here it's not even even now
in a way and let's say risky or whatever
it's just a good move so what now h5 h5
Bishop takes Knight h4 it's already
really dangerous now it's dangerous
night age what is this move actually
maybe a five maybe you can play at five
ok so maybe I must I must play it and
play it differently like was g4 and then
nitro age form
hmm maybe okay I don't want to lose on
time while thinking about that I'm just
I'm just going for it and hope that it
is indeed dangerous okay going to e8
yeah i was i was thinking Queen g3 but
maybe there is something something
better even Queen g3 looks very normal
yeah I probably must do that okay I'm i
need this rope here in the game that's
also a slight problem with this I cannot
castle long
okay 96 is what I expected but very
tricky position but should be too was
also move like intending after this to
capture 96 check at night f90 mf8 but
the bishop is so nice on c4 I really
don't want to I really don't want to
move it okay
and jam if a ticket holy Queen takes
and he threatens to take
yeah maybe I need to do that I don't I
don't I don't see much else what a
position am one thing I know if you play
this against any sort of engine you
would lose so I'm so technical yeah okay
Bishop b2 logistics checking too gnite
xfa it may be hard to hard to evaluate I
don't know check okay nothing else
really am if I take it yeah well I'm
threatening rook age 7 and 9 h 7 so it
probably needs to recapture now probably
yeah as I said probably night h7 though
it looks dangerous and then Queen g4
isn't this good or 96 taking here sure
page six this is probably good Rhea I
come on I need to play from one minute
thirty don't want to lose on time at the
end why does winning probably anyway
with many moves that they Knight f6 here
and rook takes
the ship h6 Notley not clear
that was in fact still a good defense
time morning age six he can take on age
79 bishop age six King takes as weird as
it looks check
40 seconds it would be terrible to spoil
that because it was like totally winning
probably night h7 then wasn't really
good there were many 96 was strong many
good good moves
I don't really understand anything here
Knight f3
hmm
look t5 rook takes you 5 this kind of
stuff I need to get in maybe maybe still
good I don't I don't really know the 20
seconds is the main problem Knight f3
disrupt g6 this is this is a threat and
now nine f7 probably is saving him check
yeah so hard to do hard to say anything
about this camera can probably win it
whatever which way not just luck not
just not with what I played
check-check
check check yeah I could resign but Jack
is somehow not not fine like a killer
here check check white four bits on time
yeah okay I can now look at how I could
have one in one of the probably ten ways
this is yeah yeah and as 96 is probably
just killing him right and I'd edge
seven is also winning yeah they're all
win this is this is maybe the easiest to
play simply needs to take here needs to
take here and I mean I'm an exchange up
it's not like a sacrifice something for
this position it's just just to complete
ruin okay and this is also winning and
that's I overlooked yeah this is this
even winning as well yeah whatever you
play it's all winning but I've got 40
seconds on the clock rook h6 is plus 70
km but that's not it's not so easy I
wanted to have an easy win rook h 5s
maybe maybe this is the easy one this is
that yeah this is the the absolutely
easiest win easy to play in one minute
something yeah I don't know there should
be two assaults Oh quite quite obviously
using and see a black has no move
whatsoever but okay if I simply didn't
didn't put it away check it's probably
useless to look at this I mean why it is
still winning when is still winning but
it's very tricky to do in 30 seconds
and here by Bishop f4 is plus 12 yeah
it's a it's useless to look at money
with 20 seconds you cannot expect to
find really good moves this is this is
not not enough chand after this okay
he's basically saved him he's safe now
James everything's working there nicely
together yeah maybe not how much time
did ahead of the clock I still had two
minutes here check yeah maybe I should
have should have looked a bit more at
that Bishop g6 is the only type of
reasonable move and after that I didn't
really had a good continuation
calculated so I should have really
thought about this a bit longer that
it's now this is the this is really the
easiest way to go now the problems he
cannot even do that I can just take and
when the rook in the corner is never
bothered to developed anything Hey okay
thanks for watching